So one of the things you'll do when
bringing people on to your project,
is have consultations.
You might have a designer or an engineer
come in to help you understand
what would be part of your
minimum buyable product, and
what might need to go in
a version two or version three.
To do that,
we've brought in James and Karl.
Now guys, we have this app here, this
is a prototype built out in envision.
And the idea is that it is
an essentially a to do list or
calendar app.
And I want to understand sort of
what we would go about making first,
if we wanted to make
a version zero of this.
So as you can see,
we've got these sort of welcome screens,
these sort of home screens.
And as we go on we've got a bunch of
extra features that I thought were
really cool that we added on.
We've got, you can view your tasks
by the month or by the week,
you can see an overview of
what tasks you've completed,
what proportion of tasks
you've completed over time.
You can also see tasks grouped
up in certain ways, so
you know all the tasks about cars or
all the recipes you've wanted to make.
And then you've also got
sort of a profile and
a timeline of things we've done.
And then sort of general
settings screens and a menu.
Does that make sense?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Sure.
>> So, I'm really excited
about getting this built.
First off, James, as a designer, what
are the things that you would like to
focus on in making this
a better app right now?
>> Color.
I would probably change this
color palette and then,
I really like this overview screen,
like this graphic is really cool.
But I'd probably pull some
colors from the images,
like maybe from your title bar and
use the Palette Library for
Android to make it kind
of more interesting.
And I really like this group setting.
And that's another place where
I might change up the colors,
I might use more interesting
topography to make it more impactful of
how many items I have in this
automotive area, or books or whatever,
because that's not that readable
>> That makes sense.
And Carl, how does that sound to you?
Do you think that that would be
a reasonable set of things to start
working on as every one?
>> Well, there's a lot here
in this envision prototype.
I think that we should probably talk
about some of the core elements
before progressing into building
absolutely every screen.
We probably want to talk about just the
most interesting interaction elements.
So for instance,
I have to question whether or
not we really need high
fidelity graphs at this point.
We're talking about
building a to-do app.
So, let's focus on the core
elements of managing to dos.
>> Okay.
So if I'm understanding you correctly,
we want to at least have as our first
bit, building out, making a to-do,
checking off a to-do, things like that.
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> And
do you think that it's worthwhile for
us to build out those small features?
This stuff is really cool and we wanted
to include that in the app in the end.
>> Ultimately, we can make
the app as big and featureful and
fancy as you want.
The thing that we have to do though
is express the core elements first,
the core functionality.
What are users actually
doing with this app?
And in this case they're
managing their to dos,
they're managing a little
bit of their life.
So we have to make that easy.
We have to bring that to the forefront.
There's a lot of extraneous views
here that maybe don't support that
core work flow.
And so let's, I think it would best for
us to focus on the core
elements going forward.
>> Okay.
Now James, with what Carl just said,
that we want to focus on the core
elements, what would
we be able to work on?
What would we be able
to use your time on,
to make these core elements
a little bit better?
Right now, that core element if I'm
understanding it right, we would want
to have this screen where we have these
to-dos and be able to check them off.
We would want, sort of our screen
of actually making a to-do.
And then we'd want something
like I don't know, a calendar or
something, to help manage their life.
>> Okay, so if we're focusing
on those three screens,
starting with this general
overview to do screen,
I would focus on the transitions between
that screen and the creating a to do,
just to make it more instructive and
make more intuitive for the user.
For this calendar,
probably a similar type thing, and
just focus more in making it glanceable
and more easy to read for, this
is the to do I have, this is what I need
to do at this moment, or for this day.
>> So even if we're just
building a small feature set,
there's still stuff for
you as a designer to work.
>> Oh definitely.
>> Okay, so, you know, we've been
talking about this small feature set,
and I'm not sure if this
is actually a set that we,
I have the ability to pay you guys for
yet.
I have a relatively small budget for
this and
I want to make sure that we can
get this done within that budget.
>> Well, I think we should adopt
a philosophy of launch and iterate here.
That'll give us the agility to
move where our users are going
with our software, and allow us to
really focus on min viability first.
>> Okay, so I think we probably have
enough to pay you guys to make this
initial minimum viable product
really good, really beautiful,
and actually functional.
And then from there we can use the rest
of my budget as the users dictate.
>> I think that's a great idea.
>> Perfect, so that's how
a consultation session might go.
You'll have some concerns from either
side and you'll have to balance them.
>> And at the end you'll hopefully have
a sense of what is the minimum viable
product you'll be building.
As you go through this, you'll have
multiple consultation sessions
at each release of the app,
and it might be valuable for
you to bring these concerns
in every step of the process.